foreign
lake at home you pay the same for your
mobile phone bills no matter if you
stayed at home or traveling in the
European Union
not only goods and services can move
freely in the single Market but also
workers all those working in one member
state are now guaranteed the same social
rights and rules
one common charger to rule them all one
charger that works with all devices for
two years you can exchange fix or get
reimbursed if your goods services or
digital content don't work with the DSA
we will put an end to the digital Wild
West in which the big Tech has been
deciding the rules from now on what is
illegal offline should also be illegal
online artificial intelligence must not
turn into big brother we protect your
fundamental rights we want to stop
companies from designing products that
automatically break and force you to buy
a new one durable products repair and
reuse are better for your budget and our
planet now you can chat with your
friends and family easily sending
messages from One messaging application
to another such as Viber WhatsApp or
Facebook we are fighting to ban products
made with first label from entering in
the new market